for the giants it'll be darren ruff once
again in the lead off spot and he's done
a great job getting on base in that
lead-off spot now here's is the pitch
that's driven deep down the left-hand
line way back there and goodbye
darren ruff on an 02 pitch slams one
just over the left field wall his 15th
home run of the year and the giants take
a one-nothing lead
darren ruff who is new to the leadoff
spot but he leads off this game with a
home run on a slider from kyle freeland
buster had a very strong game on
saturday against the dodgers now hitting
304 for the year 16 homers
buster swings and he drives one high and
deep to right center field that one is
on its way
into the colorado bullpen right over the
375 marker and buster posey with an
opposite field home run
two nothing giants kevin gausman the
hometown
guy back on the mound in denver two
nothing giants
two two got him and that was a beautiful
split strike three brendan rodgers
knocked in one of the rockies runs
yesterday here's the one-two
and this ball is lying toward right
center field and a diving attempt out
there by brian he can't get it rogers
will have a one out double maybe guzman
not feeling quite comfortable with the
split as he saw rogers hit a double on
that pitch
2-2 fastball got him swinging
just
blew trevor story away so kevin gawsman
a scoreless first we go to the second
two-nothing giants
for the rockies ryan mcmahon leads off
against kevin gausman giants ahead two
nothing mcmahon tall left-handed hitter
with power
first pitch to mcmahon is hit pretty
well to left center field and dubon will
watch it get over the wall
touch him all time for ryan mcmahon a
line shot
just over the wall
to the right side of the 390 marker lead
trimmed for the giants it's now 2-1 san
francisco high temperature extremely low
humidity day game here the ball can fly
two down and garrett hampson will come
up and the one-two pitch
swing and a missy struck him out with a
splitter beauty third strikeout for
guardsman one run for the rockies 2-1
giants bases loaded now with one out in
the third and roughit third bryant at
second and over at first longoria
open stance for crawford here's the 01
pitch swung on hit off the mound taken
by story on the short hop touches second
throw the first for the double play
kyle freeland gets it done
story 6-3 on the twin killing kevin
gausman pitching in his hometown
against another denver kid kyle freeland
the one-two pitch swinging to miss a
splitter on the outside
for the strikeout and that's four
strikeouts now for kevin gausman so here
is charlie blackman who was homered in
each of his last three games
and the pitch outside with the runner
going the ball is swung out and missed
the splitter off the outside for the
strikeout and the inning is over fifth
strikeout for
gospel home runs in the first for the
giants some opportunity since then but
nothing to show for it so estrada his
second at bat
that ball is hit deep down the left
field line into the corner way back
there
[Applause]
tyro estrada goes deep he's not a big
guy but he has some pretty good power
and we see it again 413 feet the
estimate on that one that's a long one
to left field three to one giants so the
first three hitters in the fourth have
all
reached against freeland home run and
two singles with gazmin coming up in a
bunning situation pulling it back
calling the butcher boy or a slash
here they come he swings away and he
bounces it right past third and it pays
off bay's head
dubat around third he'll come in to
score
wow what a
work of art there by
kevin gorsman
to make it four to one giants i mean the
third baseman mcmahon is glad he didn't
hit it right at him because he was what
was he 30 feet away from home place
estrada who homered is last time up
fifth home run of the year for tyro with
the giants he's been a real nice pickup
he's ready he throws estrada hits
another high drive down the left field
line this one is on its way and it is
gone tyro estrada
second straight at bat with a home run
this time a two run shot and it's six to
one giants the only question was was it
gonna stay fair and it did
a multi-home run game for tyro estrada
solo shot in the fourth now a two run
shot here in the fifth straight down the
line 405 feet six to one giants that
gives darren ruff a chance with first
and second two down against bowdoin
bowdoin throws ruff hits a fly ball
center field and deep going back on at
hampton all the way to the wall it's
over his head and off the bottom of the
wall
dugger's in to score gaussman around
third he's going to walk home all the
way around the third darren ruff it's a
triple for ruff
8-1 giants a shot to center field
hampson went back slammed into the wall
after it had whistled over his head
eight to one giants darren ruff having
another big game the bottom of the fifth
gaussman after having to run the bases
at altitude we'll see if gosman shows
any ill effects
and he strikes him out on the high hard
one oh no signs of fatigue in that
at-bat that's a good morning good
afternoon and good night
right back to gausman
quick reactions
two down well quick two outs this inning
that'll help after running the bases
quick reflexes by gaussman he finishes
like finishes pretty square to the plate
when you hit the ball to the left of
gausman he's usually right on time for
it
one of the two solo homers in the first
inning
buster down the right field line that's
a fair ball he tucks it in it rattles
around into the corner near the 350 sign
where blackman retrieves it and buster
has his second extra base hit of the
game he had a first inning home run and
now a double leading it off in the six
base hit to right field
[Applause]
posey to third he'll stop there as
blackman comes up throwing and the
giants have runners at first in third
with nobody out here's dubai we'll see
if mauricio can give the giants good at
bat
into right field base hit
posey scores longoria coming around
third the throw from blackman goes to
third too late to get crawford a two run
single to right for mauricio dubont his
third hit of the game
ten to one giants so now a runner at
second instead of it first and here is
brendan rodgers
and the foul tip strike three
just blew it right by him one on one out
for charlie blackman who was grounded to
second and struck out he'll pull this
one fair inside first base and it'll
head down into the corner tapia will
cruise on blackman will head towards
third relay throw is not made
charlie blackman's fourth triple of the
year makes it 10-2 san francisco chance
to play the infield back of course with
trevor story coming up
struck him out again that fast ball on
the outside
good old louisiana fastball right there
blue bayou 95. you thought at some point
maybe he would throw the split to
trevor's story but he's got a lot of
confidence in that heater right now he's
just reaching back at a couple miles an
hour
on to that fastball right by trevor
story and so two down bases empty 10-2
giants and here's garrett hampson
pitches hit towards left field this
one's deep duggar looking up and it's
over and out of here
garrett hampson goes after the first
pitch
and sends it out to left his ninth home
run of the year and the rockies trail
10-3 the rockies
send up a pinch hitter rio ruiz
got him swinging nine strikeouts for
kevin gausman we go to the eighth inning
let's see if trevor can find the swing
here been a tough afternoon for trevor
1-0 this is a drive left center field
this one has a chance and it is gone
touch him all time for trevor story
rockies are still trailing but they've
made it a 10 to five game trevor with
his 19th homer of the year two down
bases empty bottom nine
another one right back to lyon and that
will get it done the ball game's over
the giants power and then a five pitch
ninth inning from dominic leone to
finish it out ten to five the final
score
you